what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting to frito
bang featuring
polo g bless his soul before i start do
not forget to subscribe to the channel
and bring that notification
bell that way you're going to be
notified of my daily videos who didn't
film it
then it ain't all right
[Music]
okay a nice car
[Music]
okay so he's talking about lying to
judges um i'm guessing
this is part of the snitching epidemic
that goes on
in um gangs basically if you're in a
gang
snitching is a no-go so you will lie to
a judge
[Music]
okay so he bought a house in the suburbs
which i think is a great investment
because you can really get more for your
dollar
that ain't see that i'm packing this
compact x around my city i worked at
ranch
i'm living with it rapping put it out
like go go gadget i put my savage on
even though he acting
out of cash i
[Music]
okay so he's saying that he's been
traumatized so he's a hard time having
close personal relationships
on top of that he's also calling out
people that are snakes and a snake
basically
is somebody that is going to tell you
what you want to hear but behind your
back
boom they'll get you i salute to the
real one
i've
[Music]
[Music]
i like the stripes i'm a big fan of
stripes like i think stripes
look cool
[Music]
[Music]
my [ __ ] animals from the murder
capital where catching bodies casual
okay so he said he's from the murder
capital and he's catching bodies cat
casually now now you might think that
means he's hooking up with girls
wrong when he says he's catching bodies
casually that means he's killing people
see these angels guarding me
say that's what a harmony my daddy saw
this starring me when star
seemed too far to reach i'm perfect in
my artistry grew up on the carded three
shoe like we played for varsity these
slugs that hit his artery
he can't be with gang we revoked him of
his membership out here writing
statements like he working on his
penmanship he'll catch
up for racing [ __ ] around and bought the
dela show mama look i made it and i
still got all my killers up
okay so he's saying that his parents
believed in him
right and now he made it great message i
like it
he ain't nobody
[Music]
one time hopping gates trying to duck
wonder
can't be real ain't [ __ ] switching one
time you hit a lick to feed your kids
but that's fine
oh my god they got a bulldog you don't
understand i love
bulldogs oh my god okay
first of all first of all i'm gonna talk
about theme number one in this song
okay sorry i'm adjusting myself
okay theme number one in the song is buy
a house in the suburbs because
look it you can get more for your dollar
theme number two
in the song is talking about killing
people like he has he has guys that will
kill people
he's letting you know three his parents
believed in him
four i just want to add there was a
bulldog and the bulldog was really cool
so um on a scale of one to five
i'm gonna give this
a four out of five it doesn't get a five
because you know
i can never give a song of five if
they're saying to murder people that's
not my thing
but it had a cool beat and the bulldog
just added like two points
oh my goodness so let me know in the
comments what you guys would rate the
song scale of one to five don't forget
to subscribe to the channel bring that
notification
bell i'm gonna talk to you guys next
time